[Music]
and hide yo kids news submitted by
garlic naan have you ever had coconut
nah you're not as fine you I forgot
which Indian restaurant we went to but
they had a huge menu of like different
rody and naan and like all kinds of [ __ ]
and I was like mom if only I had a big
stomach a Kentucky sheriff has suspended
law enforcement in the area over a lack
of funding I heard we broke that's crazy
they just shut down they just they just
said no more policing you guys [ __ ] it
and save yourselves yeah do they got
guns at least over there the private
citizens so the sheriff posted this
really long Facebook post and at the end
of it he said folks lock your doors load
your guns and get you a barking biting
dog if the Sheriff's Office can't
protect you who will so they're pretty
much saying that they're broke that they
haven't gotten money like the money that
they were supposed to be getting for the
funding from the state or whatever yeah
was it during the shutdown oh yeah how
does he not just go to like some
government official or state official
and just say like yo bro we've got no
cash maybe the whole state doesn't got
cash well didn't mention the government
shutdown but they were saying that it
was just poor management of like the
financial situation and that Kentucky so
I heard a lot of these like states that
were heavily like dependent on like what
do you call it like like labor in
industries like manufacturing Detroit
and stuff cold like yeah things like
that that's that's their lifeline that's
their revenue and then when the factory
shut down and all those jobs went away
like I mean that's how you know
municipalities get paid you know like
firemen police all that so they get cut
now what do they do
especially if everyone's poor - there's
gonna be a higher crime rate that sucks
man does it say where he's like a city a
county a neighborhood a street Kentucky
it must be a County
it's one area right yeah just as area
but like yes I where's the colonel when
you need them
Marion County Sheriff sheriff thought
like the sheriff can you imagine if like
Kentucky Fried Chicken came out to
rescue them uh-huh because it's in
Kentucky right yeah so that means
Kentucky Fried Chicken used to come out
and save they're not known as Kentucky
Fried Chicken anymore you can't legally
call it chicken huh no Sonny Tim
McDonald's can't call it a burger
problem I thought it was cuz it wasn't
made in Kentucky anymore so what he
should go back to Kentucky I thought it
was because maybe they just rebrand like
healthier that could be it yeah cuz
there's a bone inside a lot of animals
got bones I heard they got eight-legged
chickens chickens yeah no way that's
what I heard I would love disease our
urban legends hey like a chicken if it
was healthy in life I'd be like a
Pokemon yeah let me see you look it's
false
about yours so it's a urban legend eight
breast of chicken no I looked up Snopes
it says the government forced KFC to
stop using the word chicken in their
name because they serve meat derived
from mutant animals that's false
oh so what I heard was I wouldn't
believe that mutant animal sounds so
sketch so the citizens are forced to
protect themselves exactly and so
they're saying that the State Police
will occasionally patrol but at some
time because they got stay DS over there
sometimes they only have one officer
patrolling multiple counties I heard
that's the case for a lot of small towns
and places like rural counties and stuff
yeah
one little sheriff one little [ __ ]
pen like you seen like a western movie
that's why the whole like gun argument I
think it should be regional it should
only apply not on the Federals like your
small little County or that little area
because what applies in the major city
doesn't apply to the rural counties and
you they can't sit like they can't
empathize for the situation so for
example like let's say you're in Wyoming
right and then you come from a little
cow town or something and there's only
like I don't know 20 people
and every your neighbor could be like
eight or even miles away so it's
different senses what if there's a crazy
person that comes into your farm or your
ranch how are you gonna protect your so
like no one's arguing against that I
think anyone even that's against guns is
for someone in the middle of nowhere
having one it's not really that but
we're really not but that that's what a
lot of the argument is we should we
should get rid of these assault rifles
or we should get rid of all these
high-powered rifles which they don't
even know what that means right and
that's basically like the where the
argument is is oh you don't need this
many bullets you don't need this many
whatever but how can you say that to a
person that's out there in the middle of
nowhere don't think they exist they do
that I think they don't only argue that
for people that live in the cities and
where it's like unnecessary right but
they don't specify that they try to make
a blanket law they do say ban all gone
exactly yeah so they're not they're not
a loud loud minority though I think most
people are in the middle they say if
you're in the country you can have your
gun that's I mean the most people that
aren't public say that but then the
people that are pushing an agenda yeah
most people with common sense who are
not involved in politics they're they're
saying they're thinking exactly do what
you what you what fits you but the
people that are pushing agendas and what
we see in the headlines that we see
online I think because assault rifle is
like the buzzword yeah they're pushing
no none of these but what what they
don't know is that you can make a
traditional hunt like bolt-action
hunting rifle if you paint it black and
you add accessories it can look like an
assault rifle and that's not rifle can
also look like a bolt-action rifle like
you can add wood parts to it so you
don't people are just kind of uninformed
and they're just putting a blanket
statement over all situations and just
trying to get rid of certain things like
kids who grew up in upper-middle class
suburbs who just don't see the need for
any guns at all they grew up like
thinking like there's no need for this
shall we be like Australia yeah we
should be like Australia and have it
completely gone but they're not thinking
about you know the ranchers in Arizona
that live by the border and they have to
deal with drug cartels that are driving
through their property and and and
threatening the town and they don't
think like they don't know that
situation all they think about they're
in their bubble why do you need it like
yeah
I live completely safe we're in the
frickin 21st century we don't need the
guns so I think that's the same thing
this is a good example of when you
actually need it like when your whole
Police Department shuts down a while and
it's like what the [ __ ] this you're
gonna have a lot of people like if that
were to go through then you're gonna
have a lot of people that just don't
know how to properly handle these
firearms yeah it's too late by the time
they've shut down it's like you need a
gun yesterday yeah and you needed
practice yesterday yeah so you have a
population of this County no like a
thousand yeah cuz I think it does matter
like kind of what Joe's talking about
like how that sheriff talks like if you
talk that way in San Francisco I think
it would be like appropriate to talk
that way yeah booted out probably I kind
of agree with that like it sounds so
alarming to me for him to speak that way
but it sounds like he knows everyone if
he knows everyone and they're worried
about external stuff I get it but if
you're in sepsis who say load your guns
grab your pit mole it's all then it
sounds like that movie purge or
whatever's about to happen
but I'm saying like location-specific
right in San Francisco totally different
situation you probably have cops walking
all over the place so you feel safe you
have access to to law enforcement that
can show faster maybe like it's very
different if you live in these they're
it's crazy though to me I'm not very
political like I don't know how like the
[ __ ] tears work but like you'd
imagine if this guy's lead sheriff or
whatever he could go to at least his his
mayor let alone as governor you probably
trying to keep it open for a long time
even his wife who has a full-time job
has been volunteering at the sheriff's
office multiple nights trying to keep it
going and he's like I just can't do this
there has to be a process to like right
even like people like if you guys had a
huge issue like you can write a senator
so like he's got to be able to go there
and then they gotta be able to go to the
federal if needed there has to be money
somewhere I think cuz also we we live in
California we have access to a lot of
resources it's very very different from
rural towns they're almost like a
totally different yeah it's a different
country on
11,000 population by the Esper's 11,000
yeah it's pretty small yeah that Sheriff
guy he might even be a part-time Pizza
Hut man yeah I just puts on a different
hat he's something else like two high
schools here yeah 11 thousands tiny it's
like it's like the cartoons when you go
to a small town and then the gas station
attendant is the mayor and is the hotel
it can't be like that this is John
sheriff good ol sheriff yeah that's
probably Domino's outfit patches yeah
yeah a boy scout sorry I'm cooking
pizzas right now get to your 9-1-1 call
later
yeah so you're just encouraging people
of the county to attend the court
meetings so they can know what's going
on and hopefully yes sounds well
hopefully they have enough stand-up
citizens or nothing really happens and
they just all watch each other's back
you could you could like he can control
during the day for a limited time but
then at night there's like zero per
tolling they have to rely on the State
Police which doesn't have a lot of
officers oh yeah that just sucks though
cuz like I can't I just can't imagine
that happening in America yeah you know
especially because we're like in LA it
just doesn't feel like that that can
happen here I kind of wish they didn't
put this on the news because then it
seems like all the criminals are
thinking like oh we could run it you
think you could go to another county and
say like yo bro can we borrow two
officers they don't do that though yeah
cuz they do not a [ __ ] ton here with
fires like that fires get so crazy up
north or down here and you're [ __ ]
traveling everywhere they grab people
from Nevada
yeah and Las Vegas where they also wear
thin the other department so we have a
buddy that's a sheriff and sheriff they
pretty much they're in charge of entire
county LA County which goes from like
Santa Monica I'll go to Calabasas all
the way to like Big Bear San Bernardino
but when the smaller city the
departments when they need help or if
there's just things that are just like
one-time incidents is like for example
like the Rose Parade like Pasadena has
Pasadena Police yeah but when there's a
Rose Parade and there's thousands of
people they just need backup they need
helicopters they need all that but so
they all go there to support Pasadena
but when they do that the other parts
are also suffering sure so they try it
they really try to help each other but
and then there's the budgeting issue
because I want they're doing Pasadena
stuff who's paying up my payment yeah so
is Pasadena gotten up send money and
they don't have money
yeah they got like send money back in
for that become like this big old
business transaction
my friend is a part-time volunteer
officer in New Mexico and so there's
small towns all over that need help in
the border states that don't really have
enough staff and so like you know if you
want to like you give your time you
could go through the whole thing and do
volunteer work out there so and you get
a badge and you're a sworn officer and
all that stuff but there's programs like
that that that are out there but people
don't know about them that you can do it
but I think there's a lot of like I
guess scarcity there's not enough you
know help in law enforcement so
[Music]